Alright, this discussion is
about producing custom maps
with the Google Maps API,
it's really aimed at people
who understand JavaScript,
server-side functions, and
have used the API in the past.
I'm John Coryat,
I'm the presenter.
Most people have used markers
and polylines on the maps to,
you know, indicate objects,
they are quite useful, you know,
you can display a lot of stuff
in all sorts of interesting ways,
this is a Delaunay triangulation
that I created, but they suffer
from the slow script problems,
performance, erratic map
movements when you get
past a certain number,
obviously this is an exceeding,
exceedingly large number,
but generally it seems to be
about somewhere between fifty
and a hundred and fifty objects
that cause this, this problem.
Once you exceed that problem,
you have to have a number
of methods of, of solving it in,
you know, like clustering,
using the marker manager,
things like that work to a degree,
but they do suffer from a lot of
data-intensive transactions
between the server
and the, the map.
They also have some limitations
as to what they can do.
So, in conclusion, markers and
polylines are fun and easy, but
they suffer from performance
problems, and they're not
optimum for lots of data.
I've, I've found that the best
thing to display lots of data with
is are image overlays.
And there are two types
of image overlays:
you have whole image overlays
and you have tile overlays.
An example of a whole image
overlay is a ground overlay,
the G-ground overlay, which is
a standard feature in the maps API.
This takes a flat projected image
and stretches it to the map.
Flat projected images have an
equal number of pixels North
and East and West, North, South,
East, and West, so that they're
essentially, they are
unprojected.
Does that makes sense?
Everyone understand that concept
of unprojected flat…? Projected
images look, you know, they look
more like the standard map.
Unprojected ones are these,
it's unprojected, it's kind of
squishy. Example of project,
unprojected image being
projected, you notice how it's
stretched out nicely.
This is ground overlay doing
this work. It's really a
phenomenal bunch of JavaScript
that does this. What it actually
does is divide the image into
three chunks, and stretches
each little piece a little bit
depending on, where in latitude
and longitude or latitude the
image falls, so it looks like
a seemless image. It's really
amazing how this is done.
But it, in the process, like
any JavaScript,
it's elaborate and it causes
erratic movement.
Alright, I have, let me see…
..make sure I can do this right,
okay… alright, I have a couple
of demonstrations here…
...let's see if I can get this
to work. This is a, a fitter
algorithm that, or page,
that Pam wrote.
I copied it and stripped out
some of the stuff,
but this is a clone of her
page that you can take an
image and display it on the map,
this is that same unprojected
image, and you can stretch out
the image to make it fit.
And it's really quite clever,
the way the system works,
you know, so you find how the,
how the image fits on the map,
and you get, you know,
the latitude and longitude of
the corners and you can move it
around, you can stretch it,
all kinds of fun stuff with it.
And, see right there, in a
couple steps,
I've gotten something
fairly close.
It's just a matter of
playing with it,
but once you get, once you
get something that's fairly
close, than you can create a,
a set image, here's an example
of a map that's got a ground
overlay and it's,
it's fairly snappy,
but when you start zooming in,
you get some slowish behavior out
of it.
Well this one seems to be
pretty snappy,
but you see when, even up here,
on the lakes here,
the image fits really well,
so this is ground-overlay with a,
with a projected or an
unprojected image, a flat image.
It works pretty well.
Is that snapping when you,
at the end, to the board or…?
When you're back here?
Yeah, when you hit it(?)?
Yeah, you just pick it up
and you drag it, and you drop it,
and it's just a marker.
It's not snapping to anything,
it's just using like manual tweaking.
Yeah.
So ground overlay is just defined
by it's bounding box,
and so what these basically are
are just markers that you're
dragging around to define
the bounding box.
So all this is is just one,
one, one image that's been
split up a little bit ____.
Right, yeah, so it's,
it's very clever and it's really
amazing and what's amazing is
that this image here fits so well
after you stretch it,
and when you consider
it's only three images, that's,
that's really quite phenomenal
and the way that they do it
is they, they locate pixel
boundaries and stuff
so that there's no smudging.
It's really amazing.
So you want to zoom in on
that to show what happens when
you go in really far.
Okay.
It does actually lose itself
after you go four levels in,
I think, and, it's been said
that that's a bug,
but I don't think that's a
bug as much as it's
a capability issue.
So you know, what is it,
a bug or a capability?
Let's see, that's even,
notice also the image, of course,
is smeared,
and it's pixilated because
you're stretching one image out.
So there's limits to what you
can do with this.
But if you've got some image
that you want to put on the
maps and it's, you know,
you don't, not gonna deal with
a lot of zoom levels,
this is a great way to do it.
It's simple, it's clean,
and generating a flat image
out of a program is fairly
easy if you've got the data.
Can it be transparent?
Unfortunately, you don't have
opacity options with
ground overlay.
That's, that's some of the
limitations, but this is
essentially a,
a simple easy whole-image
overlay. Yes, go ahead.
So if you made that
really high resolution image,
than it would slow down even
more with the processing ____?
Well, yeah, you take that
high resolution image and
you cram it in to a little piece,
you know, so you're still
loading the full image,
it's not trimming it out,
it's just doing what browsers
do with big images.
But it would look cleaner
closer in but it would be slower?
It would.
And also you got to remember
that that image then extends
out into the memory, so,
you know, you're you're taking
a lot of risk by using
a big image,
but still, even,
even zoomed in this fast,
or this far,
this thing works pretty well.
It just is ugly, you know.
It gets all smeary and stuff,
so it's not really usable for
the users when you
start zooming in.
But as, as a, as a way of
getting an image on the map,
this is really great.
And it can be satellite pictures,
it could be like arial photos
is a good example.
Once you locate them on the map,
they, they, you know,
move around with it,
they, they in, they zoom in,
zoom out, so it's really a
great way to do it.
Any other questions.
Yes, sir.
If you do you're marking
on the map like _______________,
when you put your picture on top,
does it come through
or is it behind the picture?
Um, as you can see from this
one here, it's on top.
So the markers are on top of
the, the ground overlay layer.
But I mean, if you put something
on the map,
and then put the picture on top,
you would lose the markings
from the map, like all
the states are gone.
Oh yes, right, you have
no opacity options with this,
this thing, and, and because
of the way that it works with,
with inter, internet explorer,
you have a choice of opacity
or transparency.
So you could create it with
an alpha channel,
but it's gonna use
the alpha loader,
an IE, and so you don't,
you can't use them both,
you have the choice of opacity
or transparency,
so if you used the alpha channel
on this, this would be,
you know, whitish covering
the ocean,
and you wouldn't have
transparency.
So, it, it's, it's good.
It's a good way to do it.
It has some limited features,
but for quick and dirty,
you can't beat it.
Anything else?
Okay. Let's go back to this.
Okay, so that's that.
In conclusion, flat images
work well.
It's difficult to align and
we have performance issues,
but other than that, it's,
it's, for quick and dirty,
fast ways of doing it.
All you need to know are
the corners,
and you can place an image
on the map.
There's a couple of really
good examples out there people
did for Area 51 where they
superimposed, you know,
things on top of airfields and,
and that's pretty cool.
What did you have on your
one, you had…?
I have the volcano.
Volcano, right.
But I've actually done it,
I did it with an old,
we had ariel photos of my house
when I was a kid,
and I'm kind of mad because
right now on Google maps,
it shows that somebody has
built a house on our land,
right? So I have,
I sent this to my family,
it's just a ground overlay
that is our old ariel photo
overlayed on the map,
so they can see what it
used to be like before
people intruded.
Right, and see, using KML,
that's even easier.
Right
You know, so you can create
that as a KML object
and load it through MyMaps even.
Right, cause ground overlay is
actually taken from KML,
so you can either do it via
the G-ground overlay class
in the maps API, or you can
find the KML that has the ground
overlay defined in it,
and it'll work the same.
The bottom line is it's
simple, it's easy to use,
and it, it's, it's fun.
Alright, the next whole
image overlay is,
I call projected overlay,
that's a class
I wrote in JavaScript.
It takes a projected image as
opposed to an unprojected
image and sticks it on the map,
in a similar way to
ground overlay,
except for it doesn't do all
that extra stretching and stuff,
so it actually ends up
being faster,
it suffers less from zooming.
And there's another really
neat effect that you can do
is you can have programs
generate the data to spit
out to the, the map.
As an example, here we have a
projected overlay and it
slaps on to the map very cleanly,
there's no stretching and
you end up with a cleaner,
easier to see image.
The really only difference
between ground overlay and
this class that I wrote is
I just stripped out a lot of
the stuff, and added,
I don't know if you've used,
what was it, T-photo?
T-photo is the, I forget,
was it Mike Williams,
was it one of his, gen, geniuses?
I believe Mike Williams
wrote T-photo,
but T-photo was a,
a similar type-thing,
except for that I needed to have
a little extra functionality,
so I borrowed from T-photo,
I borrowed from ground overlay,
and I created this one.
Everything, by the way, that you
see today, is downloadable.
All the source code, all the
server-side stuff, everything,
so you can download the data,
to create every one of
these examples, so just keep
that in mind.
So, as a demonstration, I
have a couple of examples there.
And, let's see.
And there is, there is,
you can see it's similar
to this one.
Opps, let's go back down.
Five, or mayble a little bit in.
It's similar looking to this one,
but it looks cleaner,
because there's no stretching,
and as you zoom in,
of course,
it's still looks clean.
It's, it's really a
simple thing,
this is actually counties in
the United States,
downloaded from the census and
generated out of a program
as an image.
As a projected image,
so using the Mercator(?) projection,
I have a, a, a Perl moduel
that's pretty easy to read.
It can be translated very easily
into any other languae,
but to calculate all the things
that you need to create tiles
and understand how to,
to fit them into a,
into images that,
that appear on Google maps,
it, it's written in Perl,
I don't know if any of you
are familiar with Perl,
Perl is a fairly easy
to read language.
If you've done Java or
JavaScript or C or PHP,
it's almost directly
translatable,
so if you just take this module
that I wrote and
copy the formulas out of it,
which I got out of the API,
you know, by picking through
the JavaScript,
you can create your own, or
use mine, you know, feel free.
And here's another example.
Oh, let's, let me see,
I'm a little,
got that in the wrong spot.
Here's an example of a,
of a projected overlay,
this is, these are counties
generated directly out of data
and displayed on the map.
If I move this,
this is the same stretcher thing.
It goes, it's going down to the,
it just generated
that image on the fly
using Postgres,
the database Postgres,
doing a boudingbox query
into the database to pull
out counties that fit directly
into that bounding box.
And here are the counties
that fall into that bounding box.
This is in this area, obviously.
The data, like I say,
is available from the census…
oh, one other thing you have
is you have opacity options
with this, so you can,
you know, go,
you can make a slider or
something fancy out of this,
too, I just have, you notice
it's really simple to set opacity,
you just dot, set,
set opacity with a number in it
and that's the percentage.
That's fifty and
a hundred percent.
But as you change this
little box,
goes down and does another
query and comes up with a
different list,
and another interesting thing
that's going on in this program,
is that the image being generated
by the Perl program,
this is Perl using GD,
what it does inside is it put,
attaches a cookie to this image,
and the cookie is received
into the page,
and inside that cookie
is this metadata for the
counties that is contained
within the image,
so that's kind of a cool thing.
And, so instead of having to
have the ser, the client,
the browser say,
“Okay, you just sent me
something. What's in it?”
And then go down and have the,
the, the server
re-generate that data,
cause it would have to do another
similar bounding box query to say,
“Okay, well here are the counties
that are in that image,”
what happens inside this image is
the image already does the query,
so it says,
“Okay, I've got this data,
let me just bound it up as
cookie and send it off to
the browser.”
And then the browser harvets
the cookie and erases it.
So, are they all stored in a
database as a series of points?
Yeah.
You're using Postgres GIS.
Postgres SQL straight.
Oh, not GIS.
I used post GIS, yes.
I used that to handle
shape files and do a
lot of cool things.
But when it comes to
server performance,
post GIS is a lot slower
than post SQL or Postgres
standard spatial functions.
We're talking orders
of magnitude here,
because the post GIS
library is external,
so every time you execute
a post GIS function,
it has to load it from
the external world and
then operate on the
data one at a time.
Now, with postgres, postgres
SQL itself,
the standard spatial functions
like “at”, and, you know,
the distance functions and
various things,
they are executed as
native functions.
You'll see at least ten to a
hundred times faster
using Postgres as opposed
to post GIS.
Now on the other side,
post GIS does a lot more.
You can do union sets of
polygons, you can do,
you know, intersection points,
you can do all kinds of,
you can do actual distance
calculations using miles
and such, or kilometers,
you can do that using
post GIS and a million
other things.
But, it is slower.
It's slow as the dickens.
And I did one little test a
couple months ago
where I was looking for…
I forget what it was,
it was a bounding things that
intersected with each other.
And I wrote it in post GIS
and it started executing
and I had sixty million
things I had to go through,
I estimated it would take six
hundred days to run.
And I turned around and
I rewrote it with the native SQ,
post SQL functions, and
it was done in twenty minutes.
So, you know, it was like
phenomenally faster,
and I think you'll see if
you're doing simple things,
if you're looking for
bounding boxes,
point and polygon,
if you're looking for distance,
“closest point to A”,
you know, those calculations,
they're native
functions in Postgres.
You have to load the
polygon sets,
they're different kind of data,
they're polygon data types
in Postgress, as opposed to
spatial objects in post GIS,
the data format
is slightly different.
But they are much faster
to execute,
it's easier to work with, I find
post GIS a little bit
cumbersome to work
with in programs.
The data is not as easy
to play with. Yes, go ahead.
Do other databases do
those things,
like, could you do that
in MySQL(?) or SQLserver?
I mean cause, post, the
Postgres you're talking about,
it's just like a standard,
you know, it's the one that,
you know, Sun didn't buy, right?
I mean, it's the other
really big, you know,
database that ________.
Yeah, the question is,
I have to repeat the question,
the question is, can other
databases besides
Postgres do this? The answer
is yes and no.
My SQL will do a lot of things,
but they don't,
they're really haven't
really imple,
implemented the spatial
functions fully yet.
You can do bounding box
calculations,
but you can't do point
and polygon.
You can do distance calculations,
but you can't
really do them right.
I think probably,
you know,
now that they've been
purchased by a big guy,
maybe they'll advance it,
maybe they'll abandon it.
Who knows? But, there
are some things that'll do.
Another thing that I find
that MySQL is a little bit
more cumbersome with is that
it stores the data
in the WKB format,
the well-known binary
as opposed to wkt,
well-known text.
Postgres in the polygon
format is,
is a human-readable format,
GIS is the WKB format,
it's pretty annoying,
you do a data dump,
you got garbage you
can't read it, you know,
you have to use a function
to get the data on a
readable format, and it's
a little less friendly,
I find. But Postgres,
I'm just a Postgres fan,
I guess. As far as SQL server,
Mircosoft I'm sure sells a
wonderful addition.
It's ex, it's extra.
Same with Oracle,
Oracle has a spatial.
From what I understand,
I haven't worked with it myself,
it's top-notch.
But, you know, I mean,
you just whip out the checkbook
and start writing checks
and don't stop, and every year,
you're gonna have
to write another one.
With SQLserver you go from,
you know, the workstation,
to standard, to you know,
enterprise, and you move up,
and it seems like the only
difference between them is you
can run it with a
gagillion processors,
you know, like workstations
one processor,
standards two processors,
like, they don't say
anything about GIS stuff when
you move to the next version.
I'm not really sure how
Microsoft wants to work things,
but the bottom line is
with Microsoft is
you gotta pay for it, you know,
the great thing about MySQL,
Postgres, post GIS, these
are all free, you know,
or open-source products,
so you know,
it doesn't matter how big
your company or
how small your company is, like,
for instance, my company,
USNaviguide, we're only,
you know, one, two,
or three people,
depending on the workload.
And, if I had to pay seven
thousand dollars for a license
to SQLserver and then another
four or five thousand for
the spatial functions, you know,
I wouldn't do it, couldn't do it.
I'd have to find something else.
You'd have to fire someone.
Or I'd have to charge more,
I couldn't give free things away,
like, like for instance,
you know,
the zipcode maps are all free,
they run under the free API
using, you know,
free Linux-based servers,
not free, open-source
Linux-based servers,
open-source based languages
like Postgres or, like Perl,
open-source extensions for Perl
like GD. GD is wonderful,
I don't know if any of
you have used GD,
G is, GD is extremely powerful
for image manipulation,
all this is done with GD and Perl.
GD also works with C and
also PHP,
there's image magic
is another one…
Wait, what part of this is
done with GD?
Inside…what part of this is
done with GD is inside of
the server, what I'm doing here
on this page is
I'm sending the coordinates of
this bounding box to the server,
which happens to be this laptop,
and I'm taking a Perl program,
a Perl script,
and I'm saying,
“Give me all of the counties
inside of this bounding box…
Like you,
that's a SQL statement….
Right.
Okay.
…that, that contain, that
fully contain these counties.
Then I get back the data in
the form of
human readable polygon data,
I parse it with Perl,
and then I take it and
I create filled polygons in,
with GD,
GD is image manipulations program,
and create PNG images directly
out of GD and transmit them back
to the server as
fully-formed image.
So that's what's going on here.
That's magic, man!
That's awesome!
Just did it again,
you see how fast that is?
I mean, that's incredibly fast,
and there's thirty-five hundred
polygons in this,
in this country that make
up the various counties.
So, you know, I mean,
just that fast, and you know,
when you zoom in,
as you zoom in, you know,
it does it again,
and now I put labels on them.
Oh, when it gets big enough.
Yeah, as soon as it gets
big enough to hold the label,
I put a label on it…
______ opay, opas, I don't
know how to say it….
Opacity.
So you can add opacity
and trans, like needs,
it also has transparency,
too, like….
There's a trick here,
there's a little trick here that,
that seems kind of odd,
with internet exploerer,
this works just as well,
and what's funny is
that because this is a dot PL
image it's not a dot png image,
alpha channel or transparency
and opacity work.
Don't ask me why.
It's like Mircrosoft
decided that they were
gonna treat PNGs as if,
as a you know, a secondary
data-type or image type,
and created this limitation on
them with the alpha or the,
the what's it called,
the alpha-loader,
and for some reason,
it works with Perl,
you know, with Perl
generated images.
Did you write all that stuff
down somewhere?
I mean, like, how would we
remember that, I mean that's…
You can download, like I say,
all of the code in all of
these examples is downloadable,
so you can download this program
that generates this code,
you can download the data
that produced this, you can put
them on your own Linux server
or Mac server
or whatever you want,
or put them in,
you can also do,
all this works under Windows,
Active Perl is a program
available for Windows,
Postgres with post GIS is
available for windows.
Obviously, you know, apache(?)
and all those other things
are available,
so these can be all
done under any operating system.
You might have to tweak
the various,
you know file names and
such to work under Windows,
but it should work under any
Linux server and
all those are free modules,
or open-source moduels,
from, available as rpm's or, you
know, directly from the,
the creators. I prefer to
actually compile
everything from source rather
than download them as rpm's,
you get better versions.
Plus, you have a better
understanding of what's
going on, right?
At this point,
I think I probably have
a fairly good understanding,
but it's really not that difficult.
Once you see the code,
the mystery is the fact
that you can do it,
you know, that's what I think is
the big stumbling block is
that people don't realize that
you can do this with easy
to use tools, and fast.
But the mystery is just how,
not, not, or the fact that
you can, not the how,
the how is actually very easy,
the code to do this is
incredibly simple,
it's almost like using the API,
you just initialize a new object,
and you say,
“This is a new image object,
and I'm creating a polygon,
and here are the points,
and color it this,
and, you know, make the image
this size and shoot it out
to standard out,”
you know, it's no,
no real big deal here, you know,
it's really quite simple.
It seems like a big deal,
but, I mean, that looks cool,
I just can't believe that,
all of, all of what it's doing.
Well once you see the actual
code, and it's,
the download site
is on the last page,
here, but the, the, all the
stuff is available for download,
and you can create your own
tiles, I have a tile-cutter,
I have all kinds of other
things that I'll get to
here in a minute.
We should move on.'
Okay.
Okay, does that print
out when you print it?
It would, yeah,
cause that's an image,
it's not, it's not an
overlay, so yes,
it would print out.
Or it should.
I never really tried.
I don't do much printing.
I'm not a tree-cutter,
so. But I believe…
In real estate, they like
to cut the trees.
I believe as far as printing
goes that image overlays work
because they're not objects,
they're not marker type objects,
they're just images,
so they work just like,
if you can print a map,
you can print these.
I'm not sure how the opacity and
all of that works with printing,
that's not something I'm
too familiar with.
Right, so in conclusion,
projected overlays work good
for a single viewport,
type image, it's one of the
limitations of this type of
whole image overlay is that you
have to stick to one viewport.
So you can't have an image
overlay that, that would take
up ten viewports because if
you're looking at
a 1024 by 768 viewport, and you
multiply that by ten,
you're looking at a ten thousand
pixel image, which, obviously,
is not gonna work, you know,
it may load for some people,
but it's gonna be sluggish, it's
gonna be difficult to deal with,
so you should keep,
hold(?) image overlays to
a single viewport, or like
in the case of this one here,
what you could do is you could
monitor the zooming and what,
on zoom in, refresh, re,
re-change the bounds of the map
or of the image overlay to
the map viewport,
and re-fetch a new image.
So you could do it that way,
but, and as you pan on drag-end,
you know, fetch a new image to
replace the existing one,
but that's sort of a poor-man's
tiling routine,
I suppose you could say.
But I would say that for,
for these whole image overlays,
you keep it to a single viewport,
not more than a couple
of zoom levels, and it works
well for proj, or program
generated images like this one
with the counties.
And if you need more than that,
the best thing to do
is to go to a tile system.
Okay, alright,
now for tile overlays…
anymore questions on that?
Okay, tile overlays are another
type of image overlay.
They're incredibly efficient,
as you've seen with
the Google Maps, I mean,
the way this system works
is incredibly efficient.
It runs easily on, on,
all of the browsers, very robust,
they take up very little memory
in terms of the JavaScript
that's taken to
make these things work,
it's virtually free
to use image overlays.
They're flexible, the downside
is that they're complex
to create and understand
how they work.
Now, the first thing you have to
understand is how the
tile system works.
The images are all two hundred
and fifty six by
two hundred and fifty six pixels.
You can use other sized images,
I've seen a couple of examples
where somebody tried to use a
hundred and fifty by
a hundred and fifty and they
ran into all kinds of problems.
I would say don't mess with the,
the overlay size,
leave it at two fifty six.
As soon as you go outside of
that, you start running into
little issues of the API
not being able to handle
what it should be able to handle.
According to the
API documentation,
you should be able to supply it
with any-size image.
But, in reality,
stick to the standard.
That's definitely a warning.
Don't go outside of that.
If you do, you're,
you're basically running a risk
of a malfunctioning map.
The image, the tile names are
based on an X and a Y number,
and it's extremely simple
how it works, yet,
it's very powerful.
And every time you zoom in what
happens is you start with
the whole earth, is….
let me go down,
get ahead of myself…..
you have the zoom systing,
system, the numbering scheme,
and the way the pixels work,
here's the zoom level zero for
the whole earth in
two hundred fifty six by
two hundred fifty six pixels.
The upper-left corner is
zero zero, and the lower-right
corner is two fifty five by
two fifty five,
that's the pixel numbers.
In order to build your own tiles,
you have to understand pixels.
So, at zoom level zero is
one tile,
which is four to the zero power,
okay, or one.
The number of tiles that it
contained, or the number of
tiles across and down are
actually two to the zoom power.
So here we are, zoom level one,
we take that one tile,
and we cut it into four pieces,
so here's zoom level one,
one, we now have four pieces,
and this is the whole, this
is the entire system is based
on this chopping it in half.
It's brilliant.
It really is brilliant.
Every time, every time I go
to play with this I
just marvel at the simplicity and
the brilliance of this system.
And using two fifty six,
the magic number,
as the number of pixels really
is great, too.
So you see again,
upper left tile is zero zero,
lower left one one, and
one zero one one,
that's the tile numbering scheme.
Pixels is the same,
up in the upper left had corner,
zero zero, lower righthand
now is five eleven five eleven,
because it's two fifty
six two fifty six,
starting with a zero base system.
So that's the world as four tiles.
Let me go up again.
Zoom level two.
Now we have sixteen tiles.
It's four across, same system.
Only ten twenty three in the corner,
zero up in the top.
And now we're three zero and
zero three and three three,
it's, you know, zero-based
numbering for the, the,
the pixel system,
so this is really.
Once you start understanding
how this is work,
how this works, you can,
can really leverage this
to your own use.
Now, of course,
you can use this for anything,
it doesn't have to be maps.
Here it is as, as a table.
And you can see, once you start
building up in zoom levels,
like you look down at zoom
level seventeen,
there are an awful lot of
tiles involved,
and there are just a tremendous
amount of pixles.
Seventeen million tiles at zoom
level seventeen.
Seventeen million plus, it was
seventeen point three million,
or something like that.
That's a lot of tiles.
That's why it's
very difficult to,
to deal this data out on
a world basis,
and why you need somebody
like Google to do it.
And in terms of pixels,
three point three million pixels
makes up the world, and at that,
you can show, you know,
individual buildings,
and now we have
eighteen and nineteen we're
using now, so that
even goes beyond that.
I have a little demonstration
that shows how that works.
Let me see,
I put it in the wrong place,
but I think it's here.
Okay, here we are in zoom
level zero.
Z zero, one, one pixel, you
notice how the tiles have crossed,
this is all…zoom…one tile, right?
Yeah, it's wrapping.
The wrapping world.
Not hip-hop, but
the wrapping world.
Okay, than we go up one level,
and here we have pix, zoom one,
and now we're one one, or,
here we are….
go back ____.....oops,
I zoomed in by accident, here,
cause I double-cliked on it…
Here we have zero zero again,
and one one,
so this is the
world as four.
And all these calculations are
done with this Perl module,
so the tile module
that I created,
USNaviguide underscore Google
underscore tiles dot P M,
that you can take and copy and
translate into any
language that you want.
But all these calculations are
critical if you want
to be able to create
your own tiles,
you have to use these
calculations that do it.
They're really not complicated,
and if you create some sort of
class or something that creates
these, these numbers for you,
you can leverage them
fairly easily.
And, so then we go down another…
This is kind of, I mean,
this is kind of
pathetically boring,
but you can see,
see the idea here, you know,
and as you go down…
see if we go down really
far here, you know,
here's zoom level ten,
that's tile four twenty
by four forty, and this lat,
latitude and longitude on
the Northwest corner and
the Southeast corner
and the different pixels.
So if…anyone have a
question on this?
It's kind of just a boring
depiction of what's
actually going on, but this is
important information, yes…
Could you go back to the slide
with all the numbers where you
had seventeen million tiles
but only
three point three million pixels?
Oh, that probably not,
not right, you know,
I had three people review this,
and nobody caught that,
but I think you are
absolutely right.
Yeah, your pixel numbers don't
quite grow enough in the
pattern they should.
Yes, exactly, I've got, I've,
I have a problem there,
you're right.
Yup.
So, Good catch.
Yeah, Okay, so you caught
me on that.
You know, I had this peer
reviewed by, by three
different people and nobody
caught it.
So, all three should have been
able to but I guess they just
were so dazzled by my wonderful
presentation that they didn't
bother to check the
technical details.
But no, it's bound to be,
there's bound to be an error
and I was looking for the flaw
in the Indian rug,
and there it is.
Hopefully that's the only one.
Okay, let's see….we were here…
okay here we go…alright,
so with tile overlays, you have
three types of tile overlays,
you have one's that are
cut from images,
so you have an existing image,
you have those that are static,
from data, in other words,
that they're created once,
or they're created on a schedule
and then you have one's that are
created on the fly or dynamically.
Tiles cut from images are
probably the most common-type.
Others like, for instance,
maps, or obsolete paper maps
that people have scanned in,
panoramic pictures are a really
good example, aerial photos,
such things like that,
circuit boards, even,
circuit boards,
and other kind of strange things.
I've seen documents and books
that people have put into,
into, into data, or into tiles
and, and created maps out
of them, so, you know,
you gotta think,
“What can you use this,
this user interface for?”
And essentially what you can use
it for is whatever you can think
you can use it for.
It's amazing the varied things
that you can do with this.
And, it's not just for maps,
you know, any kind of depiction
of a three dimensional thing or
a two dimensional surface
can be done with,
with this API using tiles.
And it's it's fairly easy
to do so.
There's a lot of different
resources out there to create
these tiles from images.
You have the map
cruncher from Microsoft.
It has some limitations,
but it's really very cool.
It has an interface that you can,
you, you indicate points of
interest common with the map.
And it figures out your map
from your, your page from
their your, your image,
it overlays it in the right spot,
you say, “I think it's three
or four points,” you target
on the map, like, could be a,
a city or a mountain peak or
something like that,
and then it automatically
stretches the map to the,
or the image the right shape
and cuts it into tiles.
There's some limitations on that.
It can't be used for commercial
purposes,
I believe there's a way,
there must be, it's Microsoft,
to pay for this, license it for
commercial purposes,
but the Beta that they have on
their website on the,
what is that, the virtual earth
website, is,
is for non-commercial use.
But it's very cool,
only runs under windows,
so that's kind of a drag,
but other than that,
it's very cool, very usable.
There's the automatic tile-cutter
script from Photoshop,
that's in the MapKey,
I've looked at it, I was
gonna demonstrate it here today,
but I just got CS3,
I upgraded to ten point five,
and my old photoshop didn't work,
so I had to upgrade to CS3,
and I didn't get that
till Thursday,
so I don't have a demonstration
of that, but it does work,
the problem, that the automatic
tile-cutter, the way it's
written right now is that it
uses the old numbering system
of zooms where seventeen
is the high, you know,
is the one earth and zero is the
zoom seventeen,
now I'm sure just with a couple
of quick changes in that,
it'll be up to snuff,
but that's an easy way to take an
image and cut it up into tiles,
there's one that you can
download from Crazed Monkey
dot com,
which is a unix command line,
using Image Magic,
that's a pretty cool one, too,
but it has no alignment tool,
you have to know,
where your images lie,
but if you know where
your images lie, this,
this resources is really good
because it chops them up
really quick and easy, and it
works well, I actually tried it,
and it, I was impressed with it.
And then there's another option,
which is the Perl one that
I include with this demonstration,
which you also have to know the
bounds of, but it's,
it's based on Perl and GD,
takes an image and chops it
up into little chunks,
it works really well.
At least I think it works well.
What do you need to know if
you have an image, but the
image is already like a
geotiff(?) Do you have to
tell it more is there enough
in the geotiff file…?
Well, that, that metadata is
in the image, but I don't
know, in the case of either
the unix tool or the photshop
tool, I don't believe it can
read that, that metadata.
You'd have to pull it out and
say…
You have to tell it what ____.
Right. However, using, like,
for instance, this Perl
tile-cutter that I wrote. If
you could bring it in with the,
you know, with a tiff reader,
you know module, and pull the
metadata out, you would, you
wouldn't need to tell it
anything, you could do it all
programmatically. And that
would be the ideal, you
wouldn't want to have to do
anything manual, because
you're gonna make a mistake,
and it's gonna get screwed
up, you know, that's just human
nature, if you can do it
automatic, that's the
way to do it, but definetly if
you've got a georeference tiff
in the image, and you have a
tiff-reader, which I'm sure
there's a module out there in
Perl that does that, you could
do that automatic, but you need
to know the corners in the, in
the projected or unprojected
image, you need to know the
corners where it's gonna sit
on the map in order to
successfully chop it up. But
if you know that, that's,
you know, you need to know two
things, three things, you
need to know the corners,
upper-left and lower-right,
essentially, well, which is
all the corners, you need to
know the zoom level you want
to do it with, but….
You said it won't do all the
zoom levels….?
Well, you have, you have some
issues, as far as zoom levels,
you have some issues with
images and multiple zoom
levels that are the same thing
with, as with ground projected
images. Here's an example of
an image, this is a source
image that's an actual at zoom
seven, which, for the United
States, is about five thousand
by three thousand pixels.
And, when you cut it up into
tiles, you'll see the, the
effect, you start on the far
left at zoom five, the borders
get, you know, pixilated and
they kind of dissapear, at
zoom level seven, it looks
right, but down at zoom
level nine, it's, you know,
kind of distorted and
pixilated because you're
taking one single
image and you're stretching it.
You know, you can't create
data out of nothing, so unless
it's a vector graphic, you
know, you have no way of, of
stretching it. So that's the
limitation of tiles
cut from images, you really
can't exceed a certain number
of zoom levels of either side.
It's generally two, as you can
see, if you go down one
level and up one level,
and then you have the, the one
that it's natural at, you have
a pretty good depiction. But
anymore than that and you
start lousing it up, you know,
it starts to look crappy and,
you know, what you generally
do if you're gonna do that is
you just would use another
image after you go down one
zoom level, you would have
another image that's less
detail or more detail, and cut
that one. So here's a
demonstration of…any other
questions before I go to this?
Okay. Here's a demonstration of
a…____to the next one…This
is the tile-level, tire, tile-
layer cut from an image, and
this is zoom level seven. Again,
we have the opacity options.
It looks a little different with
tile-layers, than it does with a
whole image overlay, with a
tile-image, with a tile-layer,
if you change the opacity, you
have to delete the old layer and
add a fresh one in. Which is a
little bit more cumbersome, but it
actually works pretty well. Marcel
Lomontaigne(?) wrote a cool slider
one for his county overlayout, I
don't know if anyone's ever seen
that, he brought a really nice
county-based tile overlay that
has a slider opacity system. It's
a little complicated for a
demonstration like this, but what
you can do with it is virtually
unlimited. Again, it's left to
the imagination, but here's at
zoom level…this is overlaid
with the standard hybrid level
layer that, that's used on the
satellite maps. So as you zoom
in a little further, you notice
the lines get kind of jaggedy,
and, but you still have, you
have great map movement, that's
one thing that's wonderful
about these tile systems. And,
and this is all being done on
this little laptop here, these
tiles were generated and are
being served right here locally,
as local hosts, notice it's a
local host job, so this is all
being done with this little
teeny laptop, and, but it's
very snappy, it's extremely
efficient, and I created this,
there's level nine, this is zoom
nine, and you notice now the
boundaries are all real thick.
And if we go back down to whole
country view….there we go….
Now we lose our boundaries,
they're no longer black. So you
suffer from the problem of, of
pixilation, just like you would
on an, a whole image overlay when
you, when you take an existing
image and cut it up into tiles,
but it, it, it's the next level.
If you've got a lot… go ahead.
So , to make it nice, you just
basically have to have an image
for every single zoom level,
and cut it up.
Yes, to make it nice, you
really should have, at a
minimum, one image per every
three  . That pretty
much is, is one for every other
works even better, but if
you've got one level, one image
for every level, that's
perfection, you know, you can
do a really good job.
That's what Google does,
I mean essentially.
I'm, I'm sure that's what
Google does. Now I, actually,
I have a demonstration of, of
that, as well. These are, these
are all tiles cut from static
images, so, you have an image,
doesn't change. Cut it up into
chunks. Divide those chunks into
more chunks and you end up with
tile layers that go in, in this
case, five layer, levels of zoom
for one image. Okay…that's,
that's it for that one, any
questions on that.
I have a question.
Yes?
So I understand that the
overlay is generated like with your Earth (?)
so the map that, you're matching
that up with a map from Google,
and(?) the(?) Google API?
Correct.
Okay
Yes, what the, what the map
is showing, is it's showing a,
a overlay, actually an underlay
of a county tile layer, but
overlayed on top of that is the
hybrid level, level, hybrid
layer I guess they call it,
from the satellite maps, if
you notice on the satellite maps,
it' they would show the roads
and major roads in the cities,
that's a transparent layer with
yellow written on top. You just
overlay, you can overlay that
on top anything, it's, it's
great data because it gives
you the, the basics to,
to geographically…
It has three(?) layers.
Yeah. And you can see major
roads, you can see cities,
things like that, it doesn't
give you the road detail that,
that the, the maps do, and it's
not as pretty, but if you're
trying to depict something like,
for instance, Huffington Post
had a great map for donors that
showed splotches of red and blue
for, and, and some other colors
depending on, you know, red for
Republican, obviously, and blue
for Dem, Democrat donations from
various places and it was, it
was a nice depiction, it was a
little messy, but it was a nice
depiction of, of, of using a
custom tile layer with an
overlay of, of the hybrid level
so that you can, hybrid layer,
so that you can see geographically,
“Okay, well is this New York?”
and then you could zoom in and
say, “Okay, well, this is, you
know, this is the, you know,
where I live, and this is
Chesley, or whatever, and, you
know, Manhattan in general, and
out in, you know, this is a
general area,” and you keep
zooming out, it would show a
better, a broader and broader
area. Plus, it had some other
interesting things with the way
they handled the data. But that
was  a really good example of a
data layer created, actually,
that was a data image layer
created from data with an
overlay of a hybrid. So that
wasn't done from an image map,
the, the one at Huffington Post,
but it was a, a nice depiction.
Any other questions?
Okay. Alright, so in, in
conclusion, image overlays or
tiles cut from an image have,
have, suffer from some
limitations of pixilation, much
like whole image overlays, but
they're really great for large
areas. They can be used for
many different purposes, from
anything from aerial photos and
panoramic maps to circuit boards,
and house-plans for instance is
a, is another fun one. I remember
seeing one where somebody did a
university, and they had
individual, you, where you could
zoom into the buildings and see
the layouts of the buildings and
the classrooms. And they wanted
to, I remember the Post was, they
wanted to track people inside of
the buildings, and I, I thought,
I thought that was an interesting
idea, but it seemed a little bit
Orwellian, perhaps. Okay, the next
thing is static data tiles. Now
what a static data tile is, it's
a, it's a tile leayer created not
from an image but from data, much
like the, the projected overlay
example where I showed the, the,
you know, the counties that were
created inside of a bounding box,
you can actually create entire
tile overlays directly from the
data, skipping the image step.
So if you skip the image step,
the, the advantages really are
huge, because you can put more
or less on the map depending on
the zoom level, much like what
Google does with the maps, you
can, on a high zoom level, you
show, you know, just the
population areas over a million,
and when you start zooming in,
you can say, “Okay, now I'm
gonna put labels on the map at
this level. The next zoom level
I'm gonna show minor cities.
The next zoom level in, I'm gonna
show, you know, census blocks,
or tracks,” so you have, you have
a choice you can make inside the
program as to what to display.
That gives you a huge amount of
power. Plus, the real advantage
is you can create perfect tiles,
because you're creating them for
the zoom at that, you know, at
the cre, at the time of creation,
you're assigning what's being put
on there, you're deciding, “I want
a one pixel or a two pixel boundary.
I'm deciding that, you know, I'm
gonna put a label where I can fit
it, ” etcetera, things like that.
Here's an example of tiles in the
same county system, and you notice
how much prettier they are, I put
the tile numbers up in the corner
just for reference, they don't,
obviously, don't have to be there.
But, you know, as you zoom in,
you know, Marin county looks a
lot better when it actually
traces out the bay, and when you
can put the name of the county in
there, you know, and that's
depending on the zoom level. At
zoom level seven, Marin county's
too small. If you were to put a
ti, a, a title in there, it
would look all mushy, you know,
it couldn't be readable. So
rather than put it, a, an
unreadable title, you just leave
it out. But you can decide
these things at the moment that
you're producing the tile, and,
again, all these, the programs
that generate these tiles are,
are in the downloads, so you
know, from this example, you
should be able to create your
own tile layer of counties
doing this exact same thing.
Any questions on that? Okay.
So here's a demonstration. Now,
we go to the same type of map,
and here we have the same area.
These are now, it looks pretty
much the same as the, the image
generated system, but this zoom
level seven, the natural zoom for
that other one, but as soon as we
start zooming in, you see, now it
can put labels on the map, and
it still looks nice and clean.
You zoom in even further, and,
you know, everything looks nice
and pretty. And what's really
cool about this is, it's the
area that you can cover. I have
a, in this example, in this
demonstration, I have every tile
needed to cover the United States
from zoom level five to nine.
That's, you know, thousands of
tiles, and they were fairly
easy to generate using the, the
census data. But when they're
served up, you only serve up the
ones that you need. So like, as
I'm panning across the United
States, here across the Bay Area,
actually. I'm pulling in more
tiles from this side and
scrolling them off the other, so,
you know, this wonderful tiling
system I'm sure everybody's
familiar with, but I just can't
get over it, I, I  just love this,
the way you move this thing around,
the first time  saw a Google Map,
I almost fell out of my chair, and
I said, “Man, that's for me. I
want to deal with that.” And then…
That's everybody's experience.
Right, and then we, what was it,
housing maps?
Yeah.
Housing maps was the one who
did the first hack, and I looked
at his code, and I thought, “Oh,
this is so ugly, I can't do that,
I don't want to get into this.”
And so I just bided my time, and
then the API came out in June,
the end of June of two thousand
and five, and I, I was right on
it. So I, I thought this was the
way to go, and I actually
created the business around this.
I started this out as a hobby,
and now this is all I do, full
time is, is creating, you know,
custom maps and polygons for
customers, you know, I don't
really have a job, you know,
I don't actually go to work, so
it's, it's really great, it's a
great system. But anyway, you can
see how this, this works when, as
you zoom it in and zoom it out.
That's the real, the real
advantage of creating these things
out of data directly. And I'll go
all the way out to the United
States, and you can see at zoom
level five, it's, it's a lot
prettier. Let me pan across…a
lot of counties in the world,
or in the United States, rather
…world, we think of the United
States as the world, sometimes….
And of course you have opacity,
with this, as well. Pretty much
the same thing, so….it's pretty
cool. Any questions on that?
And again, this code is
downloadable. So if you want to
create your own, what, what I
recommend doing is that you
download this code, you, you
load it on a linux server, and
run it exactly as it is, you
know, configure everything the
way, configure it the way I have
it and play with it, and add
options to it, make changes to it.
You may have to play with Perl,
and even if you're not familiar
with Perl, it shouldn't be that
much of a stretch to make changes
to these programs, because the
programs are really quite simple.
It's just parsing text, you know,
creating polygons or creating an
object and adding points to it.
It's, it's no different than
working with the API, it really
isn't. And since the, the way
that GD works is so simple, I
think that you'll probably say,
“My gosh! I can create X out of
this!” You know, “My company
needs a Y, I can do this!” And
then you can actually take,
take what I've done, and
translate it into your favorite
language. And I don't know if
dot net has image manipulating
abilities...
It does.
Well, you can probably take and
translate what I do with GD into
the dot net object very easily.
Because it's, it's all pretty
standard stuff. The important
this is that you understand how
to reference the latitude and
longitude to a pixel location
and a zoom, and that is just,
it's a simple calculation, but
if you, if you, if you start
from point and try to create a
tile directly, you're gonna say,
“This is too hard.” So you, go
through what I've done already,
decipher the, the code that I
have down on these examples,
and I think you'll find that
it's really a lot simpler than
you, than you thought. Okay?
So with the static data tiles,
the, the biggest, like,
basically, you just pre-
calculated a whole mess of images…?
Yes, they're all pre-calculated
in advance. That's one of the
limitations of static data tiles
is that, let's say, for instance,
it's counties of the United
States, well, they don't change
but once every five or six years,
there's some minor change. If
it's, if it's something like
sales data, or sales territories,
this is a big one, is sales
territories, if it's sales
territories for my company, and
the, I have a hundred and fifty
or two hundred and fifty
salesmen spread out in the
United States, and they're
constantly jockeying territories,
they've had(?), for instance, I
do a lot of territory based
systems that are used in zip
code as their base unit for
territory, you know, some
salesman A has this list of
zipcodes, salesman B has another
list, they want to see them
depicted on the map as a big
red area and a big blue area
and a big green area for the
different salesmen.
What you need to do with the
static data tile system is you
need to say, “Okay, how often
do you want an update?” And, to
generate a complete set of
tiles for a zoom levels five to
seventeen, for instance, can
take a lot of time. It's pretty
processor-intensive. I have
customers that run it on, some
of these, they'll, you know,
eight processor systems, they
can do it in four to six hours.
If you've got a standard quad
mac, or something like that, I
have a quad mac 3.0, I run it
on, it takes about six dual
processor systems,  twelve to
eighteen, if you want to run it
on a Celeron, come back next
week. You know, it's just not
gonna be produced fast. But if
you have a reasonable schedule,
once a month I'm gonna regenerate
the tiles to show sales areas,
works great, it really does.
If you can get it to, get people
to agree. Now if it's weather or
if it's something of that nature
that changes moment to moment,
it's not gonna work.
Now, what are you use, like, I
mean, you're generating these
images, but before you generate
the images that the polygons,
you know, the polygons that are
basically a bunch of just X,Y
coordinates are somewhere, where
are they at? Like, where do they
exist? If someone wants to,
“Okay, you have California and
Arizona as your sales area,”
whatever reason, and then,
“Okay, now you got Colorado, so
now we're gonna include Colorado
in there,” like what software do
they use to include Colorado now?
Okay, the question is about
source of the data. Well the
source of the data is really
wonderful: The United States
Government. This is the United
States only, the United States
government passed a rule sometime
back that all of their data is
not copywriteable, so anything
that the government produces is
free to use in any way we want.
We can do anything we want with
it. The census beuro produces
just absolutely gobs of this
data. They have a cartography
bound, boundary website, I, I
don't have the URL, the dot
URL of the top of my head, but
if you put in “cartographic
boundary census” into Google,
you get right to it. They have
states, they have counties,
they have a thing called the
ZCTA, which is a, a sort of a
zipcode, it's not really very up
to date, they have census blocks
and, I think they only have
blocks, I don't know if they
have tracks, they may have tracks
but not blocks, I'm not sure if
they have blocks, they have school
districts, they have a lot of
data, a lot of it is as of the
two thousand census, so it's not
that useful, but as far as this
demonstration and, a lot of
other uses, if you want states
and counties, great source of
data. Then there's the tiger-line
database. Tiger is a database that
covers the entire United States
down to the street level,
geo-coding. It's amazing resource
before the current version, which is
called two thousand and six SE, is a
bizarre database, seventeen different
record types, I mean it's like, if,
if any of you who are legacy programmers,
you remember what a record-type is. A
flat file with a header that has a character
in it that means it, “I am an X
record.” You know, and it's
cumbersome, difficult to use, it's
the most difficult to use sytem of
I have ever come up with. Reading
the manual, just like reading an
IRS manual, if you like doing
you're takes, you'll love tiger.
However, starting in March of this
year, I think sometime in March,
they're gonna release it, they're
gonna start releasing these, this
data as shape(?) files directly.
Oh, really?
Yes, they're gonna all be shape
files. So instead of having to
take this data, like, what I've
done is I take the Tiger data,
and I, with programs, I create
shape files. And it's very
complicated and very difficult,
I have, when they will put out a
release, it would take me over a
month of, of, of processing time
to create a complete shape file,
file, a shape file of the entire
United States down to the
sub-polygon level, called the
A-record level. Which is sixteen
million polygons that define the
United States. Now they're gonna
release that as shape files. Now,
they're not gonna, they're not
gonna release, from what I
understand, the A-file, they're,
they're gonna, which is the
sixteen million polygons, but
they're gonna release all the
other, blocks, tracks, counties,
states, they, they skipped ZCTAs,
for some reason, which actually
I'm glad of, because I sell
zip-code polygons, so if they
had published them, I would lose
a product, but they're, they're
not doing zip-codes, but they
have a lot of other great things.
They have school districts,
they have all the congressional
districts, you know, as they're
currently mapped, so this is up to
date. Congressional district or,
congressional, what is it, the
hundred and tenth congress, all
the districts are mapped out as
polygons that you can download
right now in the form of shape
files from, from that website.
So that's an incredible resource
you can do so much with it. You
know, and it's, and it's
completely copyright free,
anything you create of it, you
can re-sell it. And I do.
I create all kinds of products
out of this stuff, custom polygon
products for, for customers and
charge them a lot of money for it,
you know? Yes.
Is there anything that you can
turn from county into streetmap?
The question is can you turn
county into, county map into a
streetmap. With Tiger, you can
because they have streetlevel
data down to a very fine level.
The problem with Tiger is that
every county is responsible for
maintaining their own data. So
you have, let's say, for
instance, I'm from a county
called Desoto in Mississippi,
not from, that's where I'm
currently living, I'm actually
not from there, disclaimer. But,
the county I live in is Desoto
county Mississippi, it happens to
be a rich county, it's the richest
county in Mississippi. They have a
GAIS department to beat the band.
Their data is better than TeleAtlas.
Now, you have another county next
door, Marshall county, the poorest
county in the State. They don't
even have a GIS department I went down there the other day to
get a deed from a property I own
in Marshall county, they had a
guy working with a paper map
that's like twenty years old,
it's all wrinkled on the edge,
and they have an AS-400 computer.
An AS-400 computer to do GAIS
stuff, it's like, that's just
not right, you know. So their
data stinks because they don't
keep it up to date. Now I'm sure
when you look at, you know,
Alameda or Santa, is Santa Clara,
is it the big one here?
Their data is probably great.
They're probably within thirty
to a hundred feet on everything.
They have address level data,
you can create your own geocoders.
I have a reverse geocoder that I
created out of the Tiger data
where you can click anywhere on
a map,and it'll tell you the
address of that point, you know,
in reverse, in terms of the
standard geocoder, you give it
an address and you get a point,
reverse geocoder flips it around.
I created that from Tiger data.
These, these things are all
available for free. The problem
is it's county level as to what
the quality is. And if it's an
older city, usually it's fairly
good. New York City? Excellent
data. Los Angeles? Pretty good.
San Francisco? Wonderful. I mean
they, you know, this is the heart
of all that stuff, so their, their
stuff is wonderful. But as you
start to get out into the rural
areas, you know, sometimes they
miss stuff by a long ways. There's
a county, or there's an interstate
in Arkansas
that's off by a hundred miles. You know,
it's like, “Didn't anybody notice they
put it on the wrong place on the map?”
You know it's like, “Well, you know, it
does go through, you know, it just,
through to the wrong place.” So, that's
the problem with that data. However, on
the other side of the coin is because
it's free and it's so vast and they
cover so much, so much area you can
leverage it to a lot of purposes. And if
you have some sort of self-correcting
mechanism, you know, you can actually
correct the data yourself by……move-on?
Okay. So anyway, so static data tiles
in conclusion. They work for any area,
sorry to cut you off there, they work
for any area, they're great for large,
large geographic areas, they work for
any zoom. They're not good for time
sensitive data, and another thing
they can't do is you can't, for
instance, pass something that a,
on the client, on the browser, you
can't pass a selection data, piece
of data to get a different tile.
Now the, what you can monkey that
up by creating a lot of different
tile layers, but that's your only
different, the only way to do a
static data tile. Okay, dynamic
data tiles, dynamic data tiles
are created on the fly, they're
created when you, they're demanded,
and that's a, a, it's a pretty cool
thing. You can use it for your own
clustering algorithms on the server
instead of doing them in JavaScript.
You can do it with time-sensitive data,
like, for instance, weather or sales
data as it comes in.  You know, let's
say, for instance, you're showing houses
that are sold. If a house is sold,
and you're depicting them on a map,
it'll show, immediately, because you're,
you're creating the data, right, or the
tile right out of the data. It is dependent
on a lot of programming skill. That's
probably one of the real drawbacks of
this, and the other thing that kind
of a, a limiter on this is server
resources, because it sucks the,
the life out of your server. You
have to be, you know, pretty robust,
you have to have a good quality
server in order to be able to create
tiles on the fly. I use, my current
server is a quad three gigahertz quad
with, I think I have six gig of ram
in the thing, and I'm running a mirrored
then thousand rpm hard-drive, and it's
pretty fast, but, you know, when it gets
loaded down, it can be slow. So you have
to be, you have to weigh the advantages
first with the disadvantages. Now one of
the things that you can do is you can mix
and match. Here's an example….let me go to
this…..you can, you can mix and match
these things, so let's say, for instance,
on this map here, this is the same county,
this is a, a static tile later, layer
created from data. As the background layer,
and as I zoom in, I only have this on zoom
level nine for this demonstration, so as I
hit zoom level nine, now we have these little
points pop-up on the map. And these points,
are actually, what I'm doing here is I'm
creating these tiles in the background with
these points, and they're the cities that are,
that are contained on these points,
and what's cool about this is
is as you mouse over it, it turns
into a hand, just like a marker, but
it's not a marker, it's a point on a static
tile. And when you click it, you get an info
window. And the thing moved down and it
populated some more and we got some more
cities, in, in this thing. What I'm doing
here, actually, is each tiles carries
along with it, the metadata, that's
supports the tile as a cookie. So,
and this really, it's kind of a simple
concept, but it's fairly revolutionary,
I suppose, I, I found it so. But what
the ideas is is as you create the tile,
you have the data just like with the
county map that I, that you change the
boundaries, as you create that tile, you
have the data that supports it. So you
pass it, simply as a cookie. You just
attach it as a cookie to the image,
and the image can transport cookies,
as everybody knows, just as well as any
other thing, a page or, or anything else,
so you can then harvest that cookie and
maintain that data as an array, in this
case, what I do is I, I maintain in
this array of objects, objects by
tile-name, so when I'm over a tile,
I know by mousing over what that
tile name is, and when I hit that
point I know that there's only so
many points in that tile, so instead
of having to go iterate over this
entire array, which could be
thousands of points to locate
that specific point, I'm only
looking at the points on that,
that are contained on that tile,
because it's, the object only
has the points that are in that
tile, tile, so that maybe a
dozens instead of thousands,
so it's very snappy, you know,
I mean that's fast. But this is
simulating marker behavior, and
these points are pitiful looking,
but, you know, I, I didn't spend a
lot of time on graphics. I'm not a
graphics person, I'm a programmer,
you know, I'm, my wife says I have
no color taste, and I, I like purple
and, and green, you know. Looks good
to me, but, you know, she doesn't
like it.
So the search is done in JavaScript?
Yeah, and the point, the point
operation here is, what I'm doing
is in, in, in the JavaScript array,
and Marcela Montaigne, an associate
of mine, he wrote that, it's in this,
in this page. What's actually
happening is as the mouse moves,
everytime the mouse, this little
JavaScript chunk goes and iterates
through an array and says, “Okay,
do I have any points within ten
pixels of this point?” And if it's
within ten pixels, I switch from
an invisible marker that's located
somewhere on that map, I set the
point of that marker to that point,
and by setting the marker to that
point, it turns into a hand. So it's,
it's kind of clever. It works really
well, though, as you can see. I mean,
you, you, it, it works just as well
as the standard map, with markers.
But there are no markers. So there
is no limit, you know, you're not
limited by markers, and you can do
your clustering on the server. So you
can pick your clustering options
on the server instead of in the
client. So you may have some
secret clustering system that
you don't want to divulge.
Well, on the server, you can
do all kinds of secret stuff.
You can keep that stuff to yourself.
You don't have to publish it when
it's in JavaScript, you can't see,
keep it secret. If somebody wants
to see it and they want to copy it,
it's there for everyone to see. So,
the difference between doing it on
the server and doing it on the
browser is many fold, and security
is a big one.
Like, for instance, these points,
if somebody wanted to harvest
these points, they could get the
pixel locations only.
They couldn't get latitudes
and longitudes.
So they would
have to translate those latitudes
and longitudes back into, or I
mean those pixels, back into latitudes
and longitudes in order to harvest
your points. And it wouldn't be as
precise as your original data. So
you can hide this data from your
users and instead of just being an
xml file that you can just Firefox,
you know, look under fire bug, look
under the different things that are
loaded in that script, click on it,
and bam, there it is, all the data
that's loaded by that program. Copy,
paste, now they've got it on their
server, you know. So instead, this
is a lot trickier, cause this data
comes across as cookies and it's,
actually, they would have a real
trick of a time getting this data
out of this program and into, into
their own. It's certainly not
anything like stealing an xml file.
It would require real programming.
So, it's another advantage of using
these dynamic data tiles, and of
course, this data can change as you
do it. But there's virtually no limit
to what you can do with something like
this. I find this really cool, you know,
myself. Any questions?
Could you have map objects behind that,
too? Like did you show the streets and
all the other regular…?
Oh sure. Absolutely. This is just a
transparent tile layer. So you could put
anything you want on here…
But you have two transparent tile layers.
You could have five.
No but there, is there actually two
being drawn there, like, one on top
of another or, do you draw it all on
the server and send just one in?
No, this is, this is actually two,
two layers, this is a static data
layer that you, that you saw in the
previous demonstration overlayed with
a dynamic data layer, so these are
two layers, is there, if we look at the…
And that works in all browsers and
everything?
Yeah. It, it's standard Google maps,
stuff. This is nothing revolutionary
or different. This is the same exact
stuff that, when you look at a satellite
image with a hybrid overlay. You have one
layer that's on the bottom, overlayed by
another one that's on top, you can
choose the order in which these things
appear, too. You could put, you could
flip it the other way and make the
satellite images transparent and show
the, you know, hybrid under, but it
wouldn't be as pretty.
Right.
You know, so you can choose
which is on top and which is
on bottom. You can have multiple
layers, you know, this is two, but
I've never tried it with more, but
I'm imagining you can put as many
as you want, you can three, four,
five, you know, but every time every
layer is gonna require another tile
fetch. So there is, you know, some
limits in terms of performance. Once
you start, you know, if you had to
fetch five tiles to fill out one
layer, you know, one square, that
would be kind of a, you know, drag
on, on everything, including your
server. But, you know, the idea is
that you make your static stuff
static, you make your dynamic stuff
cheap and easy so that you lower the,
the server load, and what I actually
did in this thing here is I calculated
all the positions in advance, put them
in a field in the data base, along with
the tile number, so when I send in a
tile number to fetch, the program does
a simple Postgres SQL query, said,
“Give me the data for this tile number,”
and bam, it pops in. I don't do anything
spatial here. This is all done as a standard
integer keys, which integer keys work great,
as everybody knows. And then, of course, you
have your standard, you know, click on the
sidebar thing and, wherever that is, oh, here
it is, right up here, that's Rigley(?)
California, so…..go ahead.
So you're using GD in order to then
generate the tiles for the dynamic data?
Yes. The question is, “How is it generated?”
It's generated with GD and Perl and Postgres
doing a standard regular SQL query, and
plotting these points, I just draw a, it's
actually, I think it's a line object, in,
in GD that's like ten pixels long, but that,
the width, the thickness is ten, I think it's
ten or eight, I'm not sure, and then I do a
smaller yellow dot inside of it. So, you know, that's how I make,
it's yellow and purple.
So it's not two fifty six and two fifty six?
The tiles are, yes. I'm talking about
these little teeny points. But it's
ninety nine percent empty space, so,
you know, of that two hundred and
fifty six by two hundred and fifty
six image, I've just got little tiny
little, itsy bits points here. And
I have, I have the, the program that
generates these, the database here,
I actually downloaded this data from
geonames dot org, this is U.S. dot
zip, and then I pulled out all the
cities that had greater than three
thousand people. Yes?
What if a point is right on the edge
of a tile, and a multiple pixel image
would overlap two tiles?
The question is, “What do you do
when it's on the edge of a tile?”
Now, cleverly, what I did is I
checked. I checked to see if the
image fell within half the
distance of the width of the
image. I just moved it over a
little. So, cheated, you know.
And actually, that's, that's a
way to ob, obfuscate your data,
as well, is you can obfuscate
your data if you want to keep
the exact data from falling into
the wrong hands, you can maneuver
the points around a little bit,
you know, mess with it, so that
if somebody does copy, copy your
data, maybe the numbers spell out
the name of your company, you know,
in binary, and then you say, “Hey, this
is our data, see, it spells us,
says so right here.” So, you know,
there's, there's all kinds of
fun things you can do in there
and, I, I see a lot of questions
on the forum about security of data.
You know, when you're using JavaScript
and xml, goose-egg, you have no security.
You can try, but you have none.
Using server-side techniques,
you have lots of security, you
can do whatever you want.
So that's, that's the, the
cleverness of this. Any other
questions? Okeydoke….so let's see
…and I think that pretty much wraps
it up. So in conclusion, dynamic data
tiles on the fly offer all kinds of
flexibility, doesn't say so here,
but it's, you have the security of
being able to keep your data close
to your chest. You don't have to pass
it as, as a cookie, like I did.
You can just put the name of that
piece of data on the tile and not
pass it, keep it, keep it private.
There's a lot of things you can
do with it. But it does come at a,
at a pretty stiff price. The power
required to generate these tiles is
pretty immense, but it's still,
on this little teeny laptop,
you see how fast it was, so
it's not insurmountable.
If you have a really busy
website where you're getting
ten or twenty thousand visitors
a day, you're gonna probably
have to do some load balancing
systems, you know, use multiple
servers and, and, you know, share
the load, but that's also pretty
easy to do. So, okay, any questions,
any other questions? Alright.
Getting help. Now if you need help
on any of these things, there's the
Google Maps API discussion group.
Now we, we always recommend that
you use that resource as heavily
as you can, because there are experts
all around the world who are helping
you twenty four hours a day, seven
days a week, in England, they don't
celebrate Thanksgiving, and in,
you know, various countries,
they don't celebrate Christmas,
and New Year's in China is a
different time than, than it is here,
you know, twenty-four hours a day,
seven days a week, you can get your
question answered, usually in a
matter of minutes. And that's really
amazing, you ask a question, as long
as it's intelligently phrased,
it's not like, something like, “Help!”
you know? “Help” is not the way you ask
the question, alright, we get that a lot.
“Desperate for help” you know, it's like,
okay, this isn't a singles bar, you know,
this is a, a help forum, so, you know,
you state your, the standard rules of
asking a question hold true. State it,
the question in a short bit.
Always include a link to your
existing page. If you don't have a
link to your existing page, upload
it to Google Pages before you ask
a question, because we gotta see
the page. If you ask a question about
JavaScript, we cannot answer it by just
saying, “My page is jerky and it
doesn't peform the way I want.
How do I fix it?” That's obviously
not a good way to answer the question,
ask the question. But if you put in
a link to your page, even if you
don't have the clearest question,
we can go and look at it.
We can run it through the debugger,
we can do all kinds of stuff,
we can see, you know, where the
errors lie, and say, “Well, you know,
on line twenty three here, you missed
the variable name.” Yes.
I just forgot. I have so many
things going on in my head….
Okay. Then, there's also the Mapkey.
The Mapkey is END's website where he's,
created a wiki kind of system.
I like it. It's, it's not really
totally well organized yet,
but it's got such a wealth of
information, you know, like,
for instance, that tile cutter
and a lot of that stuff is all
there. There's all kinds of
example and knowledge. It's a huge,
huge tool that, that I recommend
everybody use. And then, of course,
Google is your friend. You know,
if you can't get your answer from,
in the time span that you need it
from the first two resources,
go to Google and just type it in.
Odds are, somebody's already
asked and answered that question, so…
Yeah, shouldn't that be your
first resource?
No, actually not. I think
that the first resource is go
to the Google maps discussion
board and search within that,
because than you're, you're not
getting, you know…
Noise.
Weird, you know, breast
enlargement things, and strange stuff.
What on earth(?) are you searching for?
Well, it seems that no matter what
you search for, you always get some
weird thing, you know….
Where's those Google, the
Google guys to fix that problem?
It's not a problem,
it's a feature.
It's a feature, right. It's a
feature. Okay, so software and
data use in the discussion, I
used Perl 5.8A with DBI, that's
the module. GD and CGI,
those are the moduels that
you need to run this under
Perl. I have two Perl moduels
that I wrote, USNaviguide
underscore Google underscore
relpicks, that's to calculate
a relative pixel location on a map.
You just pass it a latitude and a
longitude and a zoom, and it'll
bring you back the, the pixel that,
where you have to put it on the
particular image or whatever
you're working with. The tiles
moduel calculates the values of
each tile. Postgres 8.2 is what
I used with Post GIS. Anything
over Postgres 7.4 I think 7.3
works well with spatial things,
GIS, I think Post GIS 7.4 you
have to be and above. One thing,
if you're gonna use Post GIS on
a linux box, you have to build
it from source. It's really easy,
you just download the module
from the Postgres website and
go to the quickmake instructions,
it's like five steps to build a
Postgres from source. But you
need to build it from source in
order to add the Post GIS module.
If you're a windows user, Post
GIS comes included with the binary
for Postgres. And, let's see…Apache
2.0 webserver, which you can still
use, I guess, IES(?), although I
don't know why you would wanna.
Projected image dot JS JavaScript,
yeah, US Census, cartography boundary
county shape file, that was the,
the shape files, joenames dot org
US zip file, and all the data for
this example can be downloaded from
this url, including this presentation,
this presentation is a pdf, so if you
want to download that, as well, or
review it or see anything that you missed.
So that, does the zip file include these
things, this information as well?
Yeah…
Like a readme or something?
(Eh), I don't know how much
readme is there, but once you
explode it out, it, I would say
take a look at it. There's a lot
of comments in the programs. It's
kind of, I guess the Read Me is this
pdf, you know, that gives the
demonstration and the names of
everything. But all of the….
yes, go ahead.
Dash, that's a W S dash two
thousand and eight dash 0 2 4,
this month.
I'll send at the url for all
of this stuff, so you don't
have to be writing it down…
And if you want to put that
on some other, on a Google
site, that'd be fine, too.
You said you had a download
site for, you wanted, I just
put it here for, cause that's
my server, I had control over
that one. And special thanks to
Marcel le Montaigne with helping
me with some of those examples.
Any other questions? Okay, that's it.